HAS A LOT OF MANDATE.
THERE ARE COMPANIES STILL
ENFORCING THAT.
LET’S BRING IN DR. OZ THE HOST
OF THE DR. OZ SHOW A
CARDIOLOGIST AND HE’S NOT A NEW
HOT, NOW A POLITICAL CANDIDATE
TO BE THE REPUBLICAN RUNNING IN
PENNSYLVANIA
FOR THE U.S. SENATE.
DR. OZ, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING, STEVE.
LET ME JUST EXPLAIN WHY I MOVED
FROM JUST A FEW BLOCKS FROM
WHERE YOU ARE MAKING MY SHOW
WITH GREAT JOY INTO THE
POLITICAL RING.
I ACTUALLY FEEL WE’RE IN A GREAT
CRISIS AND LIKE YOU HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THIS AND COVID BROKE
THE COUNTRY IN SOME WAYS AND I
FEEL OUR VALUES ARE UNDER ATTACK
SO I’VE ASKED THE VOTERS OF
PENNSYLVANIA TO CONSIDER ME FOR
THEIR SENATOR FOR THE UNITED
STATES AND I’M GOING TO SERVE
AMERICA, IN THIS TIME OF NEED
THE BEST OF MY ABILITY.
WE NEED BETTER SOLUTIONS,
THEY’RE OUT THERE.
WE GOT TO STOP SHAMING AND
SILENCING AND BULLYING AND
CANCELING PEOPLE WITH IDEAS THAT
ARE DIFFERENT THAN OURS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY’RE GOOD
IDEAS WE SAW THAT PLAY OUT
PLENTY IN COVID AND I GOTTA SAY
MEDICINE WHEN YOU CAN’T SAY WHAT
YOU SEE , PEOPLE DIE.
SO WE GOT TO BE ABLE TO JUST DO
AT LEAST THAT, DR. BRIAN WHO WAS
JUST ARTICULATING WITH OUR
MANAGEMENT OF COVID LET’S GET
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT WE’RE
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCING SO WE
DON’T WANDER DOWN A PATH OF
MAKING THE SAME MISTAKES WE MADE
THE FIRST TIME AROUND.
AINSLEY: DR. OZ WE’RE ALL READY
TO MOVE ON WITH OUR LIVES AND
PEOPLE IN NEW YORK ARE WORRIED
THESE SCHOOLS WILL MAKE OUR KIDS
GET VACCINATED, SOME OF THEM
DON’T WANT THEIR KIDS TO HAVE
THE SHOT YET, ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHOSE KIDS HAVE ALREADY
HAD COVID.
YOU HAVE ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT
ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS, WE SEE
WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH
INFLATION.
IS IT SAFE FOR US TO MOVE ON
WITH OUR LIVES, ARE YOU WORRIED
ABOUT THIS VARIANT?
WHAT’S YOUR ADVICE?
>> I’M NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
VARIANT.
THERE ARE LOTS OF MUTATIONS ON
THE VARIANT, 32 ARE ON THE SPIKE
PROTEIN SO I UNDERSTAND WHY WE
NEED TO WATCH IT CAREFULLY, BUT
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT IT’S
MORE OF A PROBLEM THAN DELTA
VARIANT AND WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE
THAT IT’S RESISTANT TO VACCINES
AND WE DON’T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE
THAT IT’S MORE DANGEROUS TO US,
SO WHAT OTHER CRITERIA, BY WHICH
WE WOULD, FOR EXAMPLE, DECLARE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY IN NEW YORK
AND WHAT ARE THE CRITERIA TO
LIFT THAT STATE OF EMERGENCY?
WE WENT THROUGH THIS REMEMBER
TWO WEEKS TO BEND THE CURVE?
I WAS WITH YOU.
THAT METASTASIZES THIS
OVERARCHING AUTHORITARIAN
ISM THAT STARTED TO
DESTROY OUR CULTURE, OUR BELIEFS
, OUR VALUES AND THEN YOU
START TO TRAIN PEOPLE TO BE DOS
DOCIL EX, JUST FOLLOW THE
RULES AND ORDERS EVEN THOUGH
PEOPLE MAKING THE RULES DON’T
KNOW WHAT TO DO SO THEY JUST
MAKE RULES.
IT DOESN’T WORK WE’VE BEEN DOWN
THIS PATH.
STEVE: TO THAT POINT YESTERDAY
IN YOUR ROLLOUT VIDEO YOU
RELEASED SOMETHING ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, YOU SAID COVID HAS SHOWN
US OUR SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
WASHINGTON GOT IT WRONG.
THEY TOOK AWAY OUR FREEDOM.
THAT ULTIMATELY IS WHAT YOU WANT
TO TRY TO FIX.
HOW DO YOU FIX THAT?
>> WELL ONE IS TRANSPARENCIES
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY WE’VE GOT
TO EMPOWER AMERICANS.
IF YOU TAKE CHARGE OF YOUR OWN
HEALTH YOU REDUCE THE
COMPLICATIONS OF COVID-19
THAT’S SOMETHING YOU CAN DO.
I SPENT MY WHOLE CAREER
EMPOWERING PEOPLE.
MY PATIENTS, MY VIEWERS ON THE
SHOW I’LL DO IT FOR THE
CITIZENS OF PENNSYLVANIA
AND THE WHOLE COUNTRY AND I’VE
TAKEN ON BIG PHARMA SO THE ONLY
DATA YOU SEE IS NOT JUST BIG
PHARMA DATA, I’VE TAKEN ON BIG
TECH SAME STORY THEY CONTROL THE
NARRATIVE SO THEY TELL YOU
THE STORIES YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO
BELIEVE.
FIGHTS I’VE HAD WITH CHEMICAL
COMPANIES, I’VE GOT THE SCARS TO
PROVE IT, WE TALKED ABOUT SOME
OF THESE BATTLES.
I’LL KEEP WAGING THEM, I CAN NOT
BE BOUGHT.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT
THIS STUFF HONESTLY, IT’S
UNCOMFORTABLE BUT IT’S WHAT HAS
TO HAPPEN IN AMERICA.
BRIAN:  DR. OZ, A COUPLE THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, YOU REALIZE IF YOU
QUESTION DR. FAUCI YOU QUESTION
SCIENCE SO HOW DARE YOU,
QUESTION ANYTHING.
I WANT YOU TO APOLOGIZE TO
SCIENCE.
NUMBER TWO IS I BELIEVE, AND I
COULD BE WRONG ON THIS , THAT
YOU WERE TOTALLY BEFUDDLED BY
THE REACTION TO
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
YOU WERE JUST ASKING QUESTIONS
AND THE BLOWBACK, THE MAGNITUDE
OF IT, WAS SHOCKING TO YOU AS
SOMEBODY WHO CAME UP IN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION AND DOES
THAT STILL EVERYDAY.
YOU’RE ASKING THE SAME QUESTIONS
BUT NOW, YOU’RE ASKINGS MEDICAL
QUESTIONS IN A POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT AND YOU WERE JUST
ALMOST TAKEN ABACK TO THE POINT
WHERE YOU KNOCKED BACK A LITTLE.
YOU HAD TO RECALIBRATE YOUR
REMARKS.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> WHEN YOU MIX POLITICS AND
MEDICINE, YOU GET POLITICS.
WHAT WE WITNESSED NOT JUST WITH
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE BUT MANY
OTHER SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED SUBSEQUENTLY IS THAT
THERE’S A SINGLE PERSPECTIVE
THAT’S ALLOWED TO GET VACCINATED
LISTEN I THINK ONE OF THE
GREATEST ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
AMERICA THAT WE GAVE THE WORLD
THE  MRNA VACCINES THROUGH
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S OPERATION WARP
SPEED.
I’M SO HAPPY THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO DO THAT, AND I GOT VACCINATED
AND I BELIEVE IN VACCINE.
I DON’T BELIEVE IN MANDATES AND
I ALSO DON’T BELIEVE IT’S THE
ONLY PATH TO SUCCESS.
FROM DAY ONE WE’VE ARGUED
DOCTORS DON’T SEND PATIENTS HOME
WITH JUST A PRESCRIPTION OR  A
PIECE OF PAPER WITH A DIAGNOSIS,
WE SEND YOU HOME WITH A GAME
PLAN ABOUT HOW TO CURE YOURSELF
AND MAKE YOURSELF BETTER TO
EMPOWER YOU, AND COVID WE SAID,
YOU KNOW, GO HOME.
IF YOUR LIPS TURN BLUE CALL US,
BUT YOU NEED TO GET HOSPITALIZED
THAT’S NOT GOOD ENOUGH AND WHEN
YOU HAVE DOCTORS AROUND THE
WORLD OFFERING THE BEST
SOLUTIONS POSSIBLE DURING WAR,
WE SHOULD AT LEAST LISTEN TO
THEM.
TO THIS DAY WE HAVE NOT DONE
ADEQUATE QUALITY CLINICAL TRIALS
TO TEST THESE PRODUCTS.
WE HAD A PILL APPROVED YESTERDAY
BY THE FDA AND THIS PILL FROM
MERCK WAS AVAILABLE BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED.
IT WAS HERE FOR MORE THAN TWO
YEARS, WE JUST YESTERDAY HAD THE
FDA PANEL SAY YOU KNOW, IT
SAVES LIVES.
WE SHOULD APPROVE IT.
FINALLY DOCTORS FOR THE FIRST
TIME HAVE A PILL TO GIVE
PATIENTS WHO HAVE A DIAGNOSIS OF
COVID, WE SHOULD HAVE DONE MUCH
MUCH BETTER THAN THIS BUT WE
COULDN’T ASK THE QUESTIONS.
BRIAN:  BECAUSE IT’S TOO
POLITICAL.
STEVE: SO YOU KNOW, WHEN IT
COMES TO THE SENATE RACE IN
PENNSYLVANIA, YOU, OBVIOUSLY,
HAVE ENORMOUS NAME RECOGNITION
BECAUSE YOU’VE BEEN ON
TELEVISION FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
OPRAH WINFREY INTRODUCED US TO
YOU BACK IN THE DAY.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO OPRAH?
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM OPRAH ABOUT
RUNNING FOR SENATE?
>> OF COURSE I SPOKE WITH OPRAH
SHE’S MY PARTNER ON THE SHOW,
SHE’S BEEN A HUGE MENTOR,
FAVORITE WOMAN I KNOW.
I TOLD HER THAT MY INTERESTS
WERE IN POLITICS, SHE LISTENED
AND THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
SHE SAID DO WHAT YOUR HEART SAYS
TO DO.
I WANTED TO RUN THIS RACE TO
ADDRESS THE MAJOR ISSUES WE FACE
IN AMERICA, AND THE PROGNOSIS IS
GOOD.
I FEEL MORE UPBEAT ABOUT AMERICA
TODAY THAN I HAVE IN A LONG TIME
BECAUSE I’VE SEEN THE SOLUTIONS
OUT THERE.
THEY’RE FANTASTIC BUT THEY’RE
BEING SUFFOCATED SO I’M RUNNING
TO MAKE SURE THOSE GREAT IDEAS
SEE THE LIGHT OF DAY.
THAT’S WHAT THE WE’VE ALWAYS
DONE AS A COUNTRY AND HERE’S THE
PLEDGE.
I’LL BE YOUR PUBLIC SERVANT.
WE CAN REINVIGORATE AMERICA WITH
THESE GOOD IDEAS IF WE LISTEN TO
EACH OTHER AND IT’S IMPORTANT,
WE GOTTA START SEEING DIVINE
SPARK IN EACH OTHER AGAIN.
WE’RE NOT THE ENEMY OF EACH
OTHER.
AINSLEY: ARE YOU READY FOR THIS
RACE?
YOU ARE LOVED BY EVERYONE IN
AMERICA AND YOU’VE DECIDED TO
RUN AS A REPUBLICAN.
TELL US ABOUT THE THOUGHT
PROCESS, WHAT YOUR CONVERSATIONS
WERE LIKE WITH YOUR FAMILY AND
TO LEAVE SUCH A BIG JOB MAKING A
LOT OF MONEY TO GO INTO POLITICS
>> WELL, AINSLEY, THANKS FOR
BRINGING THE FAMILY ISSUE UP
IT WAS THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
OF THE DECISION BECAUSE YOU DO
TAKE YOUR WHOLE FAMILY DOWN THE
PATH SO MY YOUNGEST SON,
OLIVER, WHOSE BEEN ON THE SHOW
JUST STARTED MEDICAL SCHOOL AT
COLUMBIA, SO I FIGURED WHEN THE
YOUNGEST ONE WAS SORT OF OUT
OF THE PROCESS, I COULD GO OUT
AND DO WHAT I WANTED TO DO FOR A
WHILE WHICH IS TO SERVE OUR
NATION.
LISA IS A STRONG WOMAN AND BEST
THING I EVER DID WAS MEET HER
HERE IN PHILADELPHIA AND MARRY
HER 36 YEARS AGO SO I FEEL
BLESSED TO HAVE HER BY MY SIDE
AND ONE THING, SHE DOES SET ME
STRAIGHT.
IN MY HOUSE THE PROSECUTION
NEVER RESTS.
>> [LAUGHTER]
BRIAN:  INTERESTING.
DR. OZ WE LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING TO YOU.
IT’S GOING TO BE A WHIRL WIND,
LOOK FORWARD TO GET READY FOR
THE KNIVES.
>> [LAUGHTER]
I’M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL.
STEVE: IN HIS BUSINESS, THEY ARE
SCALPALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AINSLEY: GOD BLESS YOU, GOOD
LUCK.
I DON’T LIKE TO SAY GOOD LUCK.
I SAID THAT YESTERDAY AND TODAY.
I DON’T BELIEVE IN LUCK, I
BELIEVE BLESSINGS.
GOD BLESS.